LARRY ARNN: And
as it gets close,
he gives the orders to fire.
And Washington was
shrouded in smoke.
And the smoke was cleared,
and Washington was still
walking toward the
British on his horse.
[GENTLE MUSIC PLAYS]
What kind of virtue is courage?
STUDENT: Moral.
LARRY ARNN: Doing, right,
moral doing virtue.
And courage is a great place
to start, because it's vivid.
Everybody knows you
don't want to get killed.
If you can get your
druthers, you're
not going to be tortured.
And so the occasions
where that's at risk
are real tests,
real human tests.
You know, Jesus
says "a greater love
hath no man than to give up his
life for his friend," right?
What makes a courageous act?
STUDENT: The right disposition
towards fear and confidence.
And you have to do it for
the sake of the beautiful.
LARRY ARNN: So explain
about "right disposition."
Fear and confidence-- why are
fear and confidence opposites?
STUDENT: Courage is about
finding the mean condition
between a healthy
awareness of your fear
and your confidence that
allows you to stay and fight
the battle without throwing
away your life unnecessarily
as the rash person does.
LARRY ARNN: So all
these virtues--
moral virtues, all
the doing virtues--
have a mean between
two extremes.
And I think Kate
asked a question
when we talked a long time
yesterday about how do you
calculate where the middle is?
And the answer is, first you
identify what the extremes are.
And so rashness means what?
STUDENT: Rashness means
an excess of competence
where you aren't
afraid of anything,
and you'll just throw yourself
into the battle whatever
happens.
LARRY ARNN: And the
opposite is cowardice.
And we know what
that means, right?
And so you're going to
be in between there.
Would a fully virtuous person
be making that calculation
in those terms at the time?
What they be thinking about?
STUDENT: The end.
The goal.
LARRY ARNN: George Washington
at the Battle of Princeton
is a really great story,
because he had won in Trenton.
Christmas morning, they
went across the Delaware
because they'd just been
getting hammered for months.
And they needed to win something
in the first year of the war.
And he surprised the Hessians,
and he killed a bunch of them.
And he took Trenton.
But Cornwallis is coming
down with a bigger
force at Princeton
down in New Jersey.
And Washington sees that I
can't really be driven out
of here in a single day.
That'll deprive us of the
prestige of the victory.
So he had to go up
there and fight.
And when he got up there, the
American troops were running.
And he walked his
horse through them
and didn't look left or right.
And he just kept walking
toward the British.
And his adjutant records that
Washington couldn't have known
if anybody had come with him.
As he gets close, he
gives the orders to fire.
And there's a volley,
and Washington
is shrouded in smoke.
And Fitzwilliam put his
cap down over his face.
He couldn't stand to see
the fallen Washington.
But then he picked it up,
and the smoke was cleared,
and Washington was still
walking toward the British
on his horse.
And the Americans had
formed up behind him.
And they ran the British away.
And that's one reason
why George Washington
is the father of our country.
People saw that, and they
thought, I can trust this man.
That is the human being
in action, body and soul.
And it's fully realized
in that moment.
And that is the epitome of
moral action, which involves
thinking and decisions, too.
And where's the heart of it?
Where's the thing that makes
it a true virtue to Washington?
Is it that he didn't get shot?
Is it that they won the battle?
Is it, what?
It's in what he wanted.
The motive is all-important.
What do you want?
And what you want,
by the way, is
supremely to do with
practice, especially
through the doing virtues--
but not only.
George Washington,
I will say, he
wrote out these rules
of civil behavior.
And so when he was a little boy,
he was practicing all the time.
And the rules of civil behavior
include don't bite your nails.
Don't spit when you talk.
The last one is labor to
keep alive in your breast
the celestial fire known
as honor, I think he says--
I can't remember [INAUDIBLE],,
memory's failing me.
But that means that he intended
to developed the ability
to do that.
And the way he developed it
was by making good choices when
there's reason not to make them.
I'm Larry Arnn, president
of Hillsdale College.
You will find, if you look
at our online courses,
that they cover the whole
range of human learning,
all the high and fundamental
things everyone needs to know.
They are free,
because we have always
wished to provide sound
learning to anyone
who wishes to have it.